not ducking how could you miss me glue  to the blinky keep my [ __ ] with me i get  the backhand still to get back in the  back of the truck at the club try to  frisk me  i get so high just like i'm a hippie  back in the 60s first got me trippy i  did two thirties i'm on for 60. i'm in a  range of sport on the road trying to  lose control no i'm not messy i put the  drink and i do not miss it won't even  pull it up when i'm not busy i'm on a  mission i'm always busy carrying up  [ __ ] tracking some more breathing in  my cars right now i got for showbread  [ __ ] lindsay he got the low hand i'll  put the work here like i got four hands  and i got love for a few respects for a  couple [ __ ] but ain't no fear my heart  for no man  keep my sword on me like conan but for  the rapper so i was pulling out my cribs  and [ __ ] got a domain [ __ ] stay hanging  like her boy homie how you gonna show me  what you gon blow that purty